do you know what the round is it's the
thousand blades of Aegon's enemies a
story we agreed to tell each other over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
8 video today I want to read a very
fascinating theory about her old friend
Sir Jamie Lannister
now I do want to say this does go
completely against all of my own beliefs
but this was so well done that I just
had to read it to you anyway some of you
may categorize it as another one of
those crazy ideas but it is backed up by
some very interesting evidence to say
the least for those of you who would
like to read the original essay I will
have that link down below well let's get
started because there is a lot to go
over in today's video I will provide the
evidence for my assertion that Jamie
Lannister is azor Ahai the prince that
was promised and the valonqar all
wrapped up into one shiny morally
confused package before we begin though
let's summarise Jamie's narrative a Song
of Ice and Fire and Game of Thrones
closely follows Jamie aka the Kingslayer
as he painfully examines the nature of
his character in order to undergo an
impressive redemptive transformation for
many of us jamie has fundamentally
changed from someone we absolutely
detested early on to someone we well
kinda like I hope to explain to you here
how each of the prophecies undeniably
fit with major events related to this
transformative journey there is a single
event that is undoubtedly the most
important catalyzing event of Jamie's
Redemption story which is the loss of
Jamie's hand this is because I believe
Jamie forges his hero's sword as phrased
in the Azure Ahai prophecy by shedding
his Kingslayer persona in order to rid
himself of the Kingslayer he must first
lose the symbolic representation of this
perceived corruption his sword hand
Jamie states I was that hand directly
linking his character to his sword hand
when Qyburn is treating Jamie stump he
says he is removing the corruption a
potential double meaning that double
meaning is illustrated even more clearly
when in another scene
Qyburn says we've stymied the corruption
jaimé repeats the phrase with emphasis
showing its importance that is while
Qyburn has stymied the physical
corruption jamie repeats in the phrase
to show us that he has stymied his
corruption of character sir c2 says
things change once Jaime loses his hand
calling Jaime's han a rather important
part of him
Cersei prefers the corrupted Kingslayer
persona Jaime's transformation is
undesirable in Circe's eyes so forging a
hero's sword is metaphorical for forging
a hero's character or allowing the hero
to surface being reborn as Jaime this
begins to occur immediately after Jaime
loses that sword hand an event that was
set into motion when Jaime selfishly
attempted to save Bryan's life if you
recall in order to be the hero prophecy
states that Jaime must forge his sword
three times I believe this is because
with each attempt his connection to
Cersei corrupts him necessitating
multiple forgings this cycle will
eventually lead to the fulfillment of
the valonqar and the niece Aneesa zora
high prophecies in the same act the
death of Cersei at the hand of Jaime if
you are unfamiliar the books discuss a
prophesize hero azor Ahai that will save
man from the White Walkers the prophecy
is written in three parts each of which
can be explained using events from
Jaime's redemption story
he labored for 30 days and 30 nights
until it was done however when he went
to temperate in the water the sword
broke he was not one to give up easily
so he started over after Jamie loses his
hand he begins his ascent his first
attempt to shed the Kingslayer occurs
when he shares the King Aerys story at
Harrenhal in the bath with Brienne did
you - he is tempering Jaime and water by
confessing the story of the Kingslayer
a sign that we will begin to see a
transformation exists in this odd line
that appears in the book and television
not so hard you'll rub the skin off may
serve as another clue I believe they
says a subtle reference to the first act
of change shedding his skin Jaime
proceeds to tell the story of how he
saved King's Landing from the Mad King
Aerys after Jamie completes his
confession the water had grown cold when
Jaime opened his eyes he found himself
staring at the stump of his sword hand
the hand that made him the Kingslayer
the goat had robbed him of his glory and
his shame both at once leaving what who
am I now
Jaime subsequently passes out in the
bath the word broken can be used to
describe Jaime's physical state at that
moment Brienne calls out for help
referring to him as the Kingslayer but
he replies my name is Jaime an important
clue to that which is listed above
emphasizing the opposition of those two
constructs what happens after that scene
continues the hero's story however Jaime
is corrupted by his love for Cersei his
continual references to the things I do
for love is a reminder that he engages
in questionable moral behavior for
Cersei sake alone immediately prior to
his second redemptive act Jaime faces
the Kingslayer directly by reviewing the
history of the Kingsguard here he tells
Joffrey I still have time to do good
deeds
that exchange causes him to face his
past and desire to reforge his sword a
second time Jaime Lannister someone
forgot to write down all your great
deeds list of time the second time he
took 50 days and 50 nights to make the
sword even better than the first to
temper it this time he captured a lion
and he drove the sword into its heart
but once more the steel shattered
Jaime's second attempt to shed the
Kingslayer occurs when he defies Tywin
in Cersei he does so by freeing Tyrion
from the cells after he is implicated in
Joffrey's death he additionally
confesses the truth in regard to his
role in the Taisha story Lightbringer
imagery may be at play as we see Jaime
predominantly carrying the torch in the
dungeon as soon as Jaime releases Tyrion
from prison
Tyrion goes to the Tower of the hand to
confront Tywin there's plenty of lion
imagery as Terry and enters the Tower of
the hand it feels like they're shoving
it right in our faces really shave and
mutters my lion there's no doubt this is
purposeful however there are two ways to
approach this part of the myth depending
on whether we are addressing the TV or
book version of the events if you are
not familiar with the books taisho was
Tyrians first wife first my father had
Jaime tell me the truth go as a whole
you see
Jaime had arranged the whole thing rude
the rippers all of it he thought it was
time I had a woman when Tywin discovered
Tyrion was married to Tasha
he had Jaime tell Tyrion that Taisha was
not in love but a paid [ __ ]
Tywin then ordered his guards to
gang-raped Aishah while Tyrion watched
this is a very painful subject for
Tyrion when Jaime releases Tyrion from a
Cell Jaime confesses that Taisha was not
a [ __ ] and Jaime was always aware of
this lie with that confession Jaime
attempts once again read himself of the
Kingslayer
Jaime allowed even aided antarians
imprisonment in this case Tyrion is the
captured lion Jaime's confession is
devastating for Tyrion and he drives a
sword into the Lions heart after Tyrion
is released he finds his current love
Shae and his father's bed causing him to
kill Tywin in the TV version in order to
simplify the events the showrunners
chose to account for this prophecy by
making Tywin de Lyonne who is shot in
the heart by Tyrion as a result of
Jaime's actions there's an interesting
clue in Game of Thrones that strengthens
the validity of that theory and a Storm
of Swords Tywin is shot once in the gut
however in Game of Thrones he is struck
again in the heart there's really no
reason to include that second shot
except to account for the prophecy
however Jamie did not kill Tywin
directly right so why would he believe
that it's his fault how would it impact
his hero's journey there's an important
scene where Cersei blames Jaime and so
he blames himself
Tyrion might be a monster but at least
he killed her father on purpose
you killed him by mistake with stupidity
Jaime is told not only he murdered Tywin
but also his sense of moral
responsibility caused it
due to Circe's influence Jamie slips
once again into Kingslayer character
immediately prior to the potential third
act
he faces Edmure Tully ed Muir gives a
long important speech about Jaime in his
character as a result Jaime states that
he would throw admirers baby into the
river for Cersei
the phrase remind Jamie again of what
being the Kingslayer means immediately
prior to returning to King's Landing in
season six episode 10 this was one
Walder Frey basically told Jamie that we
are the same both encounter setting the
stage for the final acts the third time
with a heavy heart for he knew
beforehand what he must do to finish the
blade he worked for a hundred days and
nights until it was finished this time
he called for his wife Nissa Nissa and
he asked her to bare her breast after
success at Riverrun jamie returns to
King's Landing and he finds the septa
barn to the ground Cersei has murdered
the faith militant along with many
innocent citizens side note Jaime likely
saved the lives of many of these same
people when he killed the Mad King Jamie
sees Cersei on the throne and he
understands that he must kill her he
knows what he must do to finish the
blade killing Cersei will finish Jaime's
blade by removing her corrupting
influence permanently it's only a matter
of time in my view the importance of
this event is highlighted by one of the
signs of azor Ahai revealing itself the
symbol for the faith militant is the red
star furthermore each recruit of the
faith militant is marked with a red star
I believe the bleeding red star is a
reference to the mass murder of the
faith militant which occurred at the
septa bail or a clue is given to us here
he drove his sword into her bare breasts
her soul combining with this deal of the
sword creating light bringer while her
cry of anguish and ecstasy left a crack
across the face of the moon Jaime and
Cersei had the only relationship fitting
of the prophecy theirs is a love that
has been the focus of the series no
other characters could meet an exhibit a
deep meaningful love and two short
seasons theories that propose Brianna's
Nissa Nissa fall shorts Brienne's role
is no substitute for Cersei as Jaime and
Marines is a relationship of respect and
admiration not profound love at best
Brienne serves as a role model in
catalysts for Jaime's journey other
theories that cite John or Dany in
previous deaths of loved ones do not
take into a
that light bringer is prophesized to
appear immediately after the death of
Nissa Nissa the only character that
consistently fights and kills for
another all while remaining physically
attached to that character for the whole
series and refusing to leave their side
is Jamie in regard to his dedication to
Cersei this is telling that being said
just as in other parts of the myth I
think we should look for more figurative
aspects of the prophecy to reveal
themselves yes I believe this is
describing the death of Cersei but the
details are still hazy look for
symbolism around burying her breasts or
the combining of a steel insole in the
moon throughout the books there are
references to Jaime and Cersei dying
together while one could take that
literally and as evidence against a
theory I believe it's more appropriate
to relate the death of the twins into
the overarching theory outlined here yes
the Kingslayer will die with Cersei but
Jaime will not in killing Cersei Jaime
will be reborn as a Zora hi completing
the forging of the hero's sword another
prophecy of A Song of Ice and Fire is
that of the valonqar when she was a
child
Cersei Lannister visited Maggy the Frog
who told her that all of her children
would die and that Cersei would die at
the hands of the valonqar valonqar is
the word for little brother in high
Valyrian Cersei has long believed that
Tyrion to be the valonqar however I
believe Jaime is not only the valonqar
but in the same acts he will fulfill the
valonqar
and Nissa Nissa prophesies evidence
shows that these two prophesies are
linked after the deaths of her children
Cersei has openly contemplated whether
or not she could have prevented them she
wonders if Maggie the Fox prophecies
were accurate
Cersei understands that if the valonqar
prophecy is true she cannot have changed
their fates if Maggie the frogs prophecy
is true she would not feel responsible
for their demise for this reason when
Cersei realizes that Jaime is the
valonqar she would be in both anguish
and ecstasy in dying due to her
understanding that the prophecy hold
and her children were marked for death
her death will bring her relief even
Joey who else would be an ecstasy during
death in my opinion this fact cohesively
links Cersei Nissa Nissa and the
valonqar prophecies so some of you might
be asking how could Cersei be strangled
via the valonqar prophecy and also be
nice Anissa and killed by Lightbringer
this is purposeful deception
Lightbringer will not be a sword itself
but the return of Jaime's sword hand
ablaze a fiery hand is Lightbringer
what was once Jamie's corruption
embodied is reborn the mark of a
prophesy hero once the best swordsman in
Westeros Jaime will be whole once again
one very strong piece of visual evidence
occurs when meera asked Jojen when will
we know it's the end and Jojen replies
how will we know the end
no no
here is another direct reference to
Jaime's fiery hand his hand burned still
still long after they had snuffed out
the torch that they'd used to sear the
bloody stump days after he could still
feel the fire Lansing up his arm and his
fingers twisting in flames the fingers
he no longer had another passage from a
feast for crows makes yet another
reference in his dreams Jamie always had
two hands one was made of gold but it
worked just like the other recall to
Tyrion says the Cersei the day will come
when you feel safe and happy but your
joy will turn to ashes in your mouth
that comment makes it seem as if the two
will never meet again could it be that
Tyrion dies before Cersei so Cersei
believes she has avoided the prophecy
perhaps she feels safe because she
believes she will not die at the hands
of the valonqar then when Jaime
strangles her with a fiery hand it will
literally leave ashes in her mouth this
too is another piece of evidence linking
Cersei the valonqar and Nissa Nissa
prophecies don't forget Cersei points
out how cold Jaime's new hand is Jaime
is the hero he displayed a pattern of
putting others before himself
Jaime is known for saving King's Landing
from the Mad King Aerys but not for the
throne or recognition in fact he suffers
for that deed Jaime routinely preserves
life and avoids conflict even at
Riverrun Riverrun when compared to
Dragon's Bay in the Battle of the
bastards is a peaceful resolution as
much as I enjoyed those conflicts from a
purely aesthetic perspective I think
there's a reason they occurred at the
same time we can see the leadership
styles directly compared among Jamie
John and Danny Jamie is a champion for
all
unlike Danny or John who brutally kill
those that oppose them in my opinion
Jaime is a leader in a warrior that is
not motivated by his own greed for power
land etc and is much more hesitant to
engage in violent action we also know
the White Walkers are capable of
negotiation and peace
remember crash tour and his deal to
provide male children in return for
peace with the White Walkers perhaps
this is how Jaime will resolve the call
flaked what the White Walkers third
diplomacy I firmly believe that George
our Martin will not end the story with
war being the ultimate resolve diplomacy
in peace will be the answer
Georgia or Martin discusses the major
Themis conflict of the human heart and
that war sucks this is Jamie's story
what could be more painful than
sacrificing oneself sacrificing a loved
one that you consider to be a part of
yourself your twin and your one true
love the hero being the hero all along
is boring redemption and growth are
interesting Lannister's aren't evil
because they're Lannisters Starks aren't
good because they're Starks anyone is
redeemable and/or corruptible so maybe
our unlikely hero will save Westeros
from the White Walkers with his fiery
hand ablaze at its conclusion then we
will have our Song of Ice and Fire there
are a couple side notes that I want to
mention as well during season 7 episode
7 jon is demonstrating how to kill a
white in the dragon pit as Jaime
Lannister is watching John burns the
whites hand why did he choose to burn
the hand only
maybe D&D are giving us a bit of a hint
also in season 7 episode 7 as Jaime
rides away from Cersei we see him put
his golden hand inside of the glove a
single snowflake falls on the glove and
the snow immediately melts but hands of
gold are always cold aren't they
I still have my right charge when I'm
growing it but I still have my right
charge when I'm growing it back
you
you
[Music]